[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's
four 800-835-6747 now here's your host
from amazing facts international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
one of the most ingenious and daring
escapes ever achieved
took place in 1979 two families with
eight members in total
escaped the oppressive country of
communist east germany
by crossing the border to west germany
in a homemade
hot air balloon after two previous
failed attempts
and near capture the determined strelzig
and witsel families tried again
on september 16 the four adults and four
children
wedged into a 15 square foot steel and
rope basket
using a homemade flame thrower they
filled a balloon that they had secretly
made on a sewing machine
with about 1435 square yards
of different colored fabric at two in
the morning
with a glowing balloon towering 100 feet
above them the gondola rose above
east germany and it drifted for 11 miles
in 30 minutes carrying the family over
the iron curtain to freedom
where they safely touched down in west
germany's barvaria
you know the bible tells of another
eight people that floated to freedom
stay with us and we're going to learn
more on this edition of bible answers
live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
hi listening friends welcome to bible
answers live and if you've got any bible
questions
this is a live international interactive
bible study lines are open a great time
for you to call in
and ask your ques questions it's a free
phone call
that number is 800 god says that's 800
seven two nine seven we are also
streaming the program and soon we're
gonna be on uh some network stations
we're just these are pilot programs that
were
we've just recently moved into our new
studio if you want to see what it looks
like you can go to the doug batchelor
facebook page
or the amazing facts facebook page and
you'll see
the studio as it unfolds and comes
together my name is doug batchelor
my name is john ross good evening
friends and passionate as we always do
let's start the program with prayer
dear father we thank you that we have
this opportunity to open up your word
and study together
and father we recognize the bible is
your book in
order for us to correctly understand it
we need the holy spirit so we ask the
holy spirit to be with us here in the
studio and be with those who are
listening wherever they might be
in their car or at home we just pray for
your blessing in jesus name amen
amen my past today you open the program
talking about an amazing escape it's
always exciting to
read about the commitment and the hard
work of
people wanting freedom and finally
families working together
understand there were situations where
um they were sort of on the radar screen
of the authorities they began to suspect
something and so they had to
uh sew this body balloon in secret and
they were able to
bring fabric together it was just an
incredible feat
but it worked for them they actually
floated over to uh west germany
yeah just the the commitment and the the
danger not only the danger
of possibly being caught and in prison
but the danger of dying
i mean at one point the balloon caught
on fire when they were
igniting and they had to calmly put it
out with a fire extinguisher
so yeah it's just an amazing story and
it's obvious that they had some divine
help in getting across the border
but when i thought about those eight
people floating to freedom
it made me think about a time in the
bible you can read in first peter
chapter 3 verse 20 when once the divine
longsuffering waited in the days of
noah while the ark was being prepared
in which a few that his eight souls were
saved
through water they didn't float upon the
air they floated up on the water
you can read in genesis 7 17 the flood
continued
40 days on the earth the waters
increased and bore
up the ark and it rose high above the
earth
until ultimately those waters covered
the highest mountains
you know the bible tells us in the book
of matthew jesus is giving some
prophecies about the second coming
and he says in matthew chapter 24 thank
you you can read in verse 37
but as the days of noah were so also
will the coming of the son of man be
for as in the days before the flood they
were eating and drinking and marrying
and given in marriage
until the day that noah entered the ark
and they did not know
until the flood came and took them all
away so will the coming of the son of
man be
talks about how the world has become so
preoccupied with just selfish pursuits
and earthly pursuits nobody was thinking
about god
that the the flood kind of took them all
by surprise
and jesus said it's going to be that way
again just before the second coming
and we're seeing that in the world today
not only did jesus say it would be like
the days of noah
in luke chapter 17 he says is also going
to be like the days of lot
and the you know the immorality and the
perversion
and that you see back in the story of
lot
is going to be replicated in the last
days and and i think we're seeing that
prophecy fulfilled right now
so um how do you get ready for
the bible says the world will not be
destroyed next time with a flood but
it's going to be a fire
how do you survive that we've got a free
offer that talks about
how to be rescued from that calamity our
study guide is entitled
rescue from above and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
it's a free phone call the number call
is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for our amazing facts
study guide it's entitled rescue from
above
we'll send it to you for free if you're
outside of north america
we encourage you to take a look at our
website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the study
guide right there again it's called
rescue from above
we'll be ready to go to the phone lines
we've got our first caller this evening
we've got
george listening from new new jersey or
north jersey george welcome to the
program
yes north jersey where we've had a lot
of snow lately you know what i mean
yeah and thanks for calling
yeah your question tonight yes good
evening pastors yeah i was looking at
isaiah uh reading some of isaiah
chapter two the first four verses of
that chapter
talks about something to pass in the
latter days
and it kind of seems like it's talking
about the new earth but then it says
latter days so i wonder how you would
interpret that i know
some pre-millennialists who believe that
the reign of crisis on the earth
would interpret that as the millennial
age you know
but i know you don't teach that or
believe that and isaiah has a lot of
i've asked some questions before uh to
you
about isaiah that some passages seem
very difficult at times you know as to
when they take place
right so if you can enlighten me on that
on those first four
verses of second chapter of isaiah okay
well for our friends listening george
i'm going to read a few of those verses
we always know that
a lot of our folks are kind of working
or cooking in the kitchen and when i
left home karen was cooking up a storm
and sometimes they're driving down the
road so we want to just read this
the word that isaiah the son of amos saw
concerning judah and jerusalem
now will come to pass in the latter days
that the mountain of the lord's house
will be established on the top of the
mountains
and shall be exalted above the hills and
all nations shall flow to it
and many people shall come and say come
let us go up to the mountain of the lord
to the house of the god of jacob he will
teach us his ways
and we will walk in his paths for out of
zion
shall go forth the law and the word of
the lord from jerusalem
well let's just pause right there for a
minute now isaiah i think is giving what
you would call a dual prophecy here
first of all during the
time of christ with the ministry of
christ the message of truth
was not just for the jews it was for all
nations and so this is a prophecy that
when it talks about all nations flowing
to the house of the lord
when jesus walked out of the temple he
said your house has left you desolate
and the earthly sanctuary was ultimately
destroyed
christ had destroyed his temple made
with hands i will make one without hands
and he spoke of his body the church
after the outpouring of the holy spirit
christ began to build up
another spiritual house peter said we
are living stones
in that house ephesians chapter 2 says
we are being built up
in into a house a dwelling place for god
and so this was in part a prophecy that
now the gospel
the pure gospel about jesus would be
exalted where all nations could see it
and they would flow
to it so there's a there's a spiritual
analogy there
but quite literally at the end of the
millennium
when god brings the new jerusalem down
to earth and
all the wicked are destroyed the
knowledge of the lord will cover the
earth
the bible says and isaiah says that
actually
and all people will flow unto god
and it tells us that the lord god is the
temple in it
and so i i think this prophecy will
literally be fulfilled when
the kingdom of god fills the earth and
people from every tribe and nation that
are have accepted christ will
flow to the lord any thoughts on that
yes some of these prophecies seem to be
spiritual then literal right they seem
to be
a combined thing sometimes yeah there's
several places you'll find
what they call a dual prophecy let me
give you a quick example because
this comes up sometimes in matthew 24
the disciples come to jesus and they
said
when will this be the destruction of
jerusalem
and the destruction of the temple and
the second coming
and he combines his whole answer into
one soliloquy he gives there in matthew
24 and mark 13.
part of it's talking about when the
temple would be destroyed by the romans
but it's a dual prophecy that talks
about a final assault on god's people
before the second coming
so um you've got several examples of
these dual prophecies in the bible
well i hope that helps a little bit
george appreciate your calling in
and probably ought to head to another
caller okay we've got amanda listening
from texas amanda welcome to the program
hi thank you thank you for calling
yes um well my question is um
about the description of jesus in
revelation
uh chapter 1 verse 14-15
um but the description
of him in the bible is totally different
from the portrait that people have of
him
wouldn't that be deceiving everybody
well what description in the bible you
mean this one
um it's in revelation right chapter 1
yeah this is a description of christ in
heaven
i don't think it's telling us exactly
what jesus looked like
on earth where's the prophecy
pastor ross in daniel where it also says
i saw his uh it kind of describes the
lord
and i think maybe daniel 7
is another description of jesus or god
anyway
and it describes god in this glorified
state
but um i i don't know if that's telling
us you know
he was six feet tall and he had brown
eyes or blue eyes i think the verse
you're referring to is daniel chapter 10
verse six
again a very similar description that
you find in revelation
talks about eyes as flames of fire and
feet like
burial or or brass in the fire of course
this is a symbolic representation of
jesus here you got a picture of
a sword coming out of his mouth the
sharp two edge sword well
that of course is symbolic revelation is
a symbolic book so
i don't think you can take the
description that you find in revelation
chapter 1 and say well that's
that's exactly what jesus looks like now
in heaven
there's a lot of symbolism in the book
of revelation yeah so amanda when it
talks about the sword coming out of
jesus mouth
uh you probably will understand that's a
symbol
because the bible says the word of god
is sharper than any two-edged sword so
we know that jesus has the word in his
mouth
his eyes are like a flame of fire
because he sees and knows all things
uh it says his hair is like pure wool
because it says our sins will be
whiter than wool he's pure and so
i think there's a lot of analogies in
the description but he will be
visible and he will be a glorious being
when we see him in the second coming
yeah you know one of the big mysteries
there's only one
very dubious description physical
description of jesus in history
and it's probably it's what they call an
apocryphal writing meaning that you know
somebody probably manufactured it but
it's supposed to be the description of a
roman soldier
that he gave of jesus but it's and
that's where i think a lot of artists
get this conception
of he's got you know hazel air hair and
and brown eyes and he's uh
you know six feet tall or medium build
and yeah
i don't think we can have that portrait
because that's what a lot of people go
to is that portrait
yeah you know it's there's a risk as i
travel around the world not sure this is
true with pastor ross when i go to india
it's very interesting they have a very
indian picture of jesus and you see it
in the artwork there
the indian christians and when i go to
africa i see a more
african picture of jesus and when i go
to
the pacific islands i see a more
polynesian description of jesus
so everyone sort of you know
superimposes some of their ideas on what
they think jesus looks like
but we got to be careful with those
pictures because the bible warns us
against idolatry
which could be a statue it could be a
picture yeah in deuteronomy right
yeah well in exodus and deuteronomy and
even revelation
guard against idols and images yeah
so okay well i hope that helps a little
bit we thank you very much amanda
and yeah we gotta keep in mind that god
is more glorious than anything we can
imagine
all right we've got noah listening in
illinois noah welcome to bible answers
live
thanks for having me doug and uh gene my
question
is how come you never really see any
wedding ceremonies in the old testament
for example when jacob married rebecca
or
isaac got married yeah well you do see a
wedding
ceremony and not so much the ceremony
but you know there yeah i guess it's a
wedding ceremony with jacob
and leah talks about the days of the
wedding feast
and you don't see one with isaac isaac's
a very unusual account
where it tells us that basically abraham
contracted for a wife
he sent the dowry eliezer picked up a
rebecca
from the land of haran brought her back
isaac knew his wife was in route and
when he met her
says he took her to his mother's tent of
course at that point his father is like
140 years old because
isaac was 40 when he got married so
abraham's got to be 140 years old so he
didn't
have a big celebration i don't know that
says he took her to his mother's tent
and she became his wife but with jacob
there is a wedding ceremony
and then you get to the book judges it
talks about the wedding ceremony
of samson and there's some others but
um get some very interesting wedding
ceremonies after the benjamites were
destroyed where the girls went out
dancing and the men captured their wives
i'd say yeah it's that's pretty
primitive but uh i don't know if we're
answering your question noah
you answered it i just wanted to know
like how like
i didn't think that there was wedding
ceremonies in the old testament
well we in it pastor ross might find him
but talks about a
a seven-day wedding feast for jacob when
he married leah
he was supposed to marry rachel but his
father pulled a switchy
rooney on him at the last minute and he
ended up marrying leah and then he had
to
he had to end up marrying rachel too and
then he got their handmaids he got
four for the price of one you might say
but um
yes yeah you're looking that up okay so
that's yeah that's in genesis
yeah genesis chapter 29 talks about the
the wedding
and uh how that yeah jacob was deceived
he was expecting
the other sister i've got to talk to him
about that one
i'll take him off by himself and have a
little chat and say how is it you did
not know that was leah until the morning
all right all right we've got jordan
listening in tennessee jordan welcome to
the program
hi hey thanks for calling and your
question
um i was reading in matthew chapter 13
verses 3 through 9 about the seeds
i don't understand the parable that he
is talking about
matthew 13 and uh this is it starts when
he said um
a sower went out to sow and he sowed
some seeds
is there a part of it you do not
understand because jesus actually
explains it
a little later in in the same chapter
yes i know but i am have mild cp and
from four years deletion and i'm really
learning things okay and i have a
king james bible and it's kind of really
hard to read to me
well let me see if i can help you a
little bit uh
here jesus tells about a man who's
sowing seeds
and the seeds when they threw seeds out
in bible time they would do what they
call
broadcast and they quite literally would
reach into a bag of seeds they'd walk
through the field
and they'd cast their arm in a big
sweeping motion
karen and i did this last week with
poppy seeds out behind our office
and just a primitive way of broadcasting
well some of the seeds you can't control
where every seed lands
some seeds fell on good soil some seeds
fell on rocky ground
some seeds fell on the uh shallow ground
and some seeds fell on the path
and he said that you know the birds came
and got the seeds that fell on the path
the seeds that fell on the shallow
ground that was full of rocks
it um it sprang up but because it didn't
have any depth as soon as it got warm
it it died out some of the seeds fell
among the weeds
and the thorns choked so they didn't
they had to compete with the vegetation
and they kind of died off
and then some seeds fell in good soil
and they were very productive
and then christ explains that the seeds
that are snatched away by
the ravens or the birds that means when
someone hears the word of god the seed
is the word of god
someone first hears the word of god
sometimes the devil will
snatch it away and distract them and
keep them from really even
paying attention to it and when the
seeds fall among the
the thorns the cares of this life
choke it out they get too worried about
well you know how am i going to
serve god and they worry so much about
making money and their job and the other
uh personal needs of life
and then when it says some seed has
shallow ground if it doesn't put down
roots
uh they don't nurture it and when they
hear the word of god
they don't read they don't pray and it
just doesn't really even take root
so this is the way that different people
respond when they hear the bible
preached
and hopefully that helps a little bit
jordan and we appreciate your calling in
with your question tonight
all right we've got jerry listening in
oregon jerry welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors basically i have
a lifelong friend who has been a good
person but he's never made a christian
commitment
he was diagnosed with bone cancer
recently and he's going to go into
hospice shortly and he's finally
verbally to me acknowledge the lord
and he lives 300 miles away no church
affiliation i'll be visiting him
but i'm don't know what to do about the
baptism
issue again bone cancers you know can be
extremely painful
usually highly sedated yeah
no i understand my mother died from bone
cancer
well you know if you have a chance to
visit with him and he's still lucid
it's wonderful that he has opened his
mind to god
don't be afraid to ask him just in the
simplest terms
does he believe that god first of all he
knows he's sinned
does he believe the promise of god that
god sent jesus
in the world to suffer for the sins of
the world and that would include the
sins of your friend
and if he acknowledges that he believes
that
then say have you asked god to forgive
your sins
for christ's sake will you accept that
jesus died for your sins
and be optimistic that he'll say yes
and then say well let's ask him right
now yeah and
pray with him and just say you might
even ask him see you know can you repeat
after me
dear lord i know i'm a sinner i'm sorry
for my sins
i repent i accept jesus sacrifice in my
behalf
and just you know you'll even find
online
some very simple outlines of biblically
how do you lead a person to christ
and it's a very simple it's a choice
that you can make and you can help him
with that choice
you don't have to be a pastor he doesn't
have to be baptized if
if he can't be baptized you can tell him
jesus will give him credit for his
baptism christ was baptized he never
sinned
he can get credit for jesus baptism so
don't let that be an obstacle to his
having peace in his final hours that god
will forgive his sins
well okay then uh i'm
without sounding haughty i've got a fair
biblical knowledge and i'm
a christian uh but it expresses desire
when i should i do this and for example
in a bathtub if he
feels he can physically do manage if
if if the hospital or his circumstances
will accommodate that
i actually i went to one lady who was
felt very strongly she wanted to be
baptized she was also dying from
a lung cancer in this case and she said
can we use my bathtub i said absolutely
and she at that point had she kind of
wasted away where she was only about 90
pounds and
her son lifted her up put her in the
bathtub and i baptized her
and uh she just came out just smiling
and and
felt great peace at that so you can do
that
i don't think baptism will be an
obstacle to their salvation if they're
you know
on their deathbed um you know some
people
but if it'll give him peace and you can
do it then by all means
maybe i shouldn't use the word deathbed
but he's he's been told basically he has
between three weeks and three months
and as you know he's going to be most
likely being morphine or
sitting yeah could be on a lot of pain
well you know even
even when you're under the influence
i've talked to people who are
on morphine and they can still
understand
so i'll pray that god gives you wisdom
jerry that's wonderful you're going to
go see your friend
and and maybe in his closing earthly
days
you can be a source of great
encouragement and peace for him and we
we pray that's the case
all right thank you for your call jerry
we've got faith listening
in texas faith welcome to the program
hi hey you got a great name hi faith
hi my question is what's the difference
between murder and kill
okay good question now if you if you
have a mosquito biting you on the arm
and you slap him
you will not be arrested by the police
for murder murder is a crime where you
take
away an innocent human life
if a soldier goes to war
and he's ordered to defend his country
and sometimes in doing that
he has to shoot the enemy that soldier
will never be accused of
murder um and if a policeman
is protecting people who are being
robbed and he has to shoot someone and
they die
it is killing but it's not murder now
the ten commandment says thou
shalt do no murder i know it says in the
in king james it's translated thou shalt
not kill but
technically it actually says thou shalt
do no murder and when jesus quotes that
commandment in the new testament
he does say it that way he says you
shall not murder
we're not to take innocent human life
and so
uh that's the difference you know um you
know every time you pull a weed
you're killing something technically
yeah so yeah does that help at all
yes okay you're not thinking about
murdering anyone are you
no okay good just making sure all right
hey well we're really thankful you
called in faith appreciate that
you have a good night and by the way
you're about 10 years old we have
a special series of study guides pastor
ross and i did both video
and lessons called amazing adventure you
can just type in amazing adventure
in google and it will take you to the
amazing facts
bible study series and we think you'd
really enjoy that faith if you've not
already seen it
thank you for your call we've got uh
next caller from new jersey java
java welcome to the program thank you
very much
uh i have a conflict over the passage
uh the heavens belong to
god and the earth is given to man
and uh the conflict seems to be growing
greater
with all the explorations into space
yeah well uh first of all what verse are
you talking about because i don't know
that passage in the bible
oh it isn't it's in the old testament do
you know where
yes i do i'm surprised you don't though
well give me the reference please
it's a very well-known verse
thank you very much sir okay did i mean
to put you on the spot but i
i haven't heard that verse before i mean
it does say that you know god made the
heavens and the earth
in genesis but i don't remember the part
where it says that uh
you know the heavens belong to god but
the earth belongs to man it does say
that god gave adam dominion
over the earth so i was just wanting to
make sure before i answered
exactly what verse she was referring to
sometimes people hear part of a verse
and part of a a saying
from culture and they think it's in the
bible but um
it's not friends that's why we're here
we're going to try and answer more bible
questions in just a minute don't go
anywhere we're coming back
you can still call in with your
questions 800 god says
and we're back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on
bible answers live order your copy today
at
afbookstore.com or by calling
1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800 4637
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live we are back listening
friends
thank you for staying with us and if you
have a bible question
the number to call in with your question
is 800-463-7297
and that's 800 god says we are streaming
on facebook you can watch the program
right now and listen
by going to the amazing facts facebook
page or the doug
batchelor facebook page and i am doug
batchelor my name is john ross
and we've got some colas lined up pastor
doug so we'll go to the next one we have
martin listening from michigan martin
welcome to the program
thank you yeah i have a bible verse
that i want to understand better okay
it's in corinthians 3 3
for as much as ye are manifestly
declared
to be the epistle of christ
thus writ not with the ink but with the
spirit of the living god
not tables of stone but in fleshly
tables
of the heart when i read this bible
verse pastors
i started writing the letter to god
and i have about 10 pages so far
so you want me to share with you what we
think that verse means i
i the way i understood it it was like
telling me to write a letter to god but
then
is that the same as just praying
well let's talk about that for just a
second when paul says
um in romans i'm sorry for second
corinthians chapter three
he said uh i'll start with verse two you
are our epistle now the word epistle
means letter and i think you know that
written in our hearts known and read by
all men paul is saying to the church
members you know
the change in your life is seen by all
men you are the epistle that we wrote
through the words that we speak
they've been written in your heart and
now people see the change in your life
and then he says in verse 3 clearly you
are an epistle of christ
ministered by us written not with ink
but by the spirit of the living god not
on tables of stone but on the tablets of
flesh that is on the heart
you can read where it says in
ecclesiastes and in jeremiah
and in hebrews chapter 8 that the new
covenant
is written he says i'll take the stony
heart out of your flesh and i'll give
you a heart of flesh
and the new covenant is written on our
hearts
and the word of god is written on our
hearts and that changes our lives our
lives are now
guided by the word and not by a letter
written in stone
and so i think that's what paul is
emphasizing here you want to
add anything to that yeah not that it's
wrong to to write down your thoughts
um maybe even write down a prayer you
have the psalms many of which are
prayers that were written down
but god doesn't need us to write down
our prayers we can pray
and god can hear and he will answer but
sometimes it is helpful to kind of
organize our thoughts and then write
them down
but i think this verse pastor as you
mentioned this is a living
letter where we're example of christ's
grace to those around us they can see
allies have been changed
and it's a testimony or a witness and i
think that is the primary
reference here that paul is making yep
very good
hey thank you martin appreciate that
call we've got david listening in new
york david welcome to the program
hi how you doing um i'm puzzled by
romans 10 4. okay
you want us to read that says christ
christ is the end of the law what does
exactly does that mean yeah now when you
say
law in the jewish mind there were
several categories of law
there were a number of ceremonial laws
that started when god
called the hebrew nation and for
instance the law
about circumcision sacrificing lambs
in the temple the priesthood the bible
tells us that when jesus died on the
cross
that the veil in the temple was ripped
from top to bottom because now
it's not a physical temple it's uh the
church
god's people are a living temple and
tells us the high priests
rent his robes and it's not the earthly
levitical high priest
anymore now the bible says we're a
nation of kings and priests
and so all the ceremonial laws have been
done away with
the law is about keeping the annual
sabbaths and the
feast days and the things that had to do
with the sanctuary
christ is our passover lamb it's not
saying the ten commandments are done
away with because
that's a law that god spoke with his
voice he wrote with his own finger he
wrote it in stone it's a very different
nature
clearly it is still wrong to murder to
lie to commit adultery to
use god's name in vain so forth and so
uh it's talking about jesus was the
fulfillment of all these ceremonial laws
that were shadows that pointed to him
you know also if you look at the verse
just ahead verse 3 it talks about a
group of people who were trying to
obtain
righteousness by their works it says in
seeking to establish their own
righteousness if not submitted to the
righteousness of god
then it says christ is the end of the
law for righteousness
so here it's talking about how do we
obtain the righteousness that is needed
for entry into heaven it's not the
result of works it comes by faith in
jesus and then i think he goes on to
explain it even further
and that faith in christ should be
manifest in the way a person lives
our life should reflect the fact that we
are committed to christ and so that's
not taken away from
holy living or others telling us how one
ought to live
by receiving christ right and paul has
this debate
often in galatians and the big debate
there in galatians was over
circumcision in particular he's saying
you know that's not the that's not the
avenue to righteousness thank you very
much david hope that helps
we've got paul listening in indiana paul
welcome to the program
thank you can you hear me yes loud and
clear
all right i have a question about
judgment um uh
specifically in matthew 19 28.
the you know the old testament and
throughout the bible the
it talks about god judging and or god
judging through jesus um you know
deuteronomy ezekiel roman's acts but in
matthew and in revelation 20 verse 4
it talks about judgment given over to
the saints or
to some others that sit on the throne so
i just wonder you know what what you
thought about that
yeah and keep in mind uh judging
in the bible did not always mean the way
we
think of a judge where they sit down and
you've got them there they got their
wooden gavel
and they're going innocent guilty i find
you guilty guilty innocent
uh there were judges in bible times that
would
they were supposed to exalt god and
you've got the
roughly 12 judges if you include samuel
i think you know samson was a judge and
talks about
deborah and barrack and these different
judges
they were leaders and so when it talks
about the 12 apostles sitting on 12
thrones judging they were not like
different circuit courts that were you
know
dealing with dmv speeding tickets and so
some of the judgment you read about in
revelation chapter 20
is talking about a judgment where the
redeemed or evaluating
the judgments of god uh and they may
even be you know affirming that god is
righteous
in not giving those fallen angels
another chance
that they're going to go to the lake of
fire but
i think here we talk about the 12
apostles you'll be judging the 12th
he's saying through eternity they're
going to be in thrones
they're going to be in positions of
glorifying god and leadership
but it won't be judgment the way we
think of it here on earth
okay i appreciate it thank you all right
thanks so much
we've got brian listening in michigan
brian you're on bible answers live
hello thank you for taking my call yeah
thanks for calling
um i've got a question here uh
i i've always been closer to god all my
life
but i got a little say arrogant about it
and over
i just realized yes i'm nervous i get
anxiety when i get on the phone like
this but anyways
all of a sudden about two or three
months ago i saw my sins through
somebody else's eyes and realized i've
been spending the last 20 years
pretty much living in sin so i
straightened my life out
i cut out all media i just really got
down to
just focusing on christ listening to
sermons instead of watching movies
and one of the sermons that's popped up
one of the things popped up three or
four times is doug batcher
where he says that grieving the holy
spirit and then he says
there's some in the bible that didn't
even know they lost it so now also
i'm in fear because there's nothing more
scary to me than
separation from god how do i know if i
grieve the holy spirit away from myself
or not
well based on what you're telling me uh
you've got conviction of sin
i think people when they grieve away the
holy spirit they don't even have that
gift of conviction the other thing is
you're you're making reforms it sounds
like the spirit's working in your life
to
turn away from what is evil and and to
draw near to god
and that's that's the holy spirit that
draws you so
you know i'm i'm not your judge but i
would i would guess
from the fruit of what you're telling me
that you still have an interest in god
and uh one thing you said did kind of
trigger a concern for me you said i'm
straightening myself out
i think i know what you mean by that and
that you're you're trying to make
practical changes in your life
but ultimately uh you we really need to
trust god to
transform us and that's one thing that
went through my mind
is you know would i even be able to do
this on my own anyways
and that just came into my head before i
called you go wait a minute if i'm
making these changes am i making them or
you know can i even do that on my own or
is the holy spirit doing this
and that's what i can do it sounds like
the spirit of god's working in your mind
right now i mean
i i wouldn't worry about that um i i
mean you know i shouldn't say you should
never
worry about grieving away the holy
spirit but i don't think that that's
something you've done based on what
you're sharing
i think you're for that i yeah yeah
that's
i just you know um it's a hard life
and you know there's so much
distractions out there it is getting
tougher but
um i married when i was 40 years old i'm
58 when i was 40 i
i was a sabbath keeper since i was six
raised in a sunday church and
then when i turned 40 i realized i just
wasted my life i've been doing sports
athletics all stuff no girlfriend for
like 20 years and all sudden i've got on
my ease i prayed my
and god answered my prayer with a wife
on the other side of the world from the
philippines who was a seventh-day
adventist
and um yeah she's been working on my
life too
and um that's how i got found you and
i am thankful for you to be there
because you have taught me a lot i gotta
thank you for that before i let you go
well that's okay i sure appreciate that
thanks so much brian and we do have a
book
talks about uh the holy spirit that's
right and grieving away the holy spirit
what that means
we've got the book it's entitled i'm
thinking we have several pastor dog we
have one
that's called life in the spirit that
talks about uh the power of the holy
spirit transforming somebody's life and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks the number to call
for that is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book called life
in the spirit we'll be happy to send it
to you
we also have a book talking about the
unpardonable sin i think it's called
um point of no return yes
it's actually an encouraging book but it
says what is and what is not
grieving away the holy spirit and we'll
also be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks
we've got rachel listening in arizona
rachel welcome to the program
hi good evening hi
hi um my question is concerning
revelation 18
23 um do you want to read it first or
sure and it says and the light of a
candle shall shine no more at all in
thee
and the voice of the bridegroom and of
the bride shall be heard no more at all
in thee
for thy merchants were the great men of
the earth for by them thy sorceries
by uh for by thy sorceries were all
nations deceived
right and so um i've been looking up so
the question
is concerning um the word um
pharmic pharma kiosk
yeah that's sorceries that's where we
get the word pharmacy
yes so the question is could revelation
um chapter 18 be referring to how the
world will attempt to solve the plagues
in the last days through pharmaceuticals
you know i've not thought of that i i
have
i have thought because uh sorcerers used
to use drugs
and i have thought we are living in a
time where there's a lot of drug abuse
and that you know the devil has he
snared so many people with
addictions to alcohol and
opioids and heroin and you name it you
know crack and meth and
yeah this a lot of people have been
deceived
by drugs i was in that generation where
we were all
taking hallucinogenics i don't hesitate
telling people this because they think
i'm still having a flashback when i
preach
but uh i was in that generation where we
were taking mushrooms and
hallucinogenics trying to find god and
it was a big deception all you found is
really confusion
but that's pharmacea you know
sorceries and i think in the in the
context here
is talking about the fall of babylon we
know that there are
a number of false christs in the last
days there will be false miracles
and that'll actually be used by the
devil to gather and galvanize support
for his false claims at the end of time
so
there's also a reference to that here in
in this passage in revelation 18.
yeah thank you rachel next caller that
we have is
isaac from arizona hi zach welcome to
the program
oh hello hi do you know if you've
written the lamb's book of life
well the bible tells us that if we
accept the provision that jesus has made
through his sacrifice i should say the
provision that god the father made in
giving his son
that when we accept that covenant and we
ask god to forgive our sins and we
repent of our sins confess our sins
and that we with our hearts take up our
cross and say lord we want to follow you
if we're baptized i believe then
it's our names it's a covenant we're
making with god that our names are
entered into the
to the book of life and um
that we've just got that promise um
in in revelation it also talks about the
names being in the book of life
in one of the churches he said if if you
don't repent i'll take your name out of
the book
so it must be in the book of life for
church members right well we have that
verse and i find it here in first john 1
verse 9 it says if we confess our sins
he's faithful and just to forgive us and
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness
so heartfelt confession just coming to
god acknowledging our need
of a savior confessing our sins that
gets our name written in the lamb's book
of life but we want to make sure it
stays in the lamb's book of life and
that's why paul says i die daily it's a
day by day surrendering of self to
christ
you know we do have a book past today
it's called three steps to heaven and i
think it will cover these uh very
important questions
how do we get our name in the lamb's
book of life how do we keep it in the
last book of life
we'll be happy to send that book to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book it's called
three steps to heaven or get in the mail
if you're outside of north america you
can read the book for free online
at the amazing facts website next
quarter that we have is damon listening
from
oklahoma city oklahoma damon welcome to
the program
hey how you guys doing good thanks for
calling
oh thanks um so i had a question about
the virgin birth
i seen a debate online and they were
going back and forth whether it was the
holy spirit of joseph
and the people who were arguing joseph
used um
two two verses and i was wanting to know
what you guys thought about it
um they used second samuel 17 12.
and then first chronicles 17 11.
all right well let's read second samuel
17 12 so
we shall come upon him in some place
where he shall be found and we will
light upon him as the dew falls upon the
ground and him
and all the men that are with him and
there shall not be left so much as one
is that what you're talking about uh
no it was a second samuel 17 12 i
believe sure it wasn't first samuel 17
12.
um i just read second samuel oh 17 12. i
i apologize i read sec second samuel 17
2 17 12 let me go here you know that is
1712.
all right let's try let's try first
samuel 17 12 and let's see if that hits
the jackpot
so david was the son of the aphrophite
that bethlehem judea whose name was
jesse and he had eight sons and the man
went among them for an old man in the
days of saul
and then you're talking about the other
verse where it says that david was
among uh seven brothers
uh no i must have got the verse wrong i
thought it was
uh what about let's try first chronicles
17 11.
yeah i got the verse right here let me
read that while you turn to that passage
it says in the shall be
when your days are fulfilled you must go
to be with your fathers
and i will set up your seed after you
and will be
of your sons and i'll establish his
kingdom
so i was probably talking about the
lineage yeah of christ
so you said people were arguing they
were using these verses and they were
arguing about
the the divinity of joseph or whether it
was through david
well no the um virgin birth they were
saying that the verses were saying that
it was joseph who was
actually the one who you know got got it
mary
impregnated not the holy spirit
well you know the bible tells us if you
read in luke it traces the genealogy of
jesus through
mary's father and so
mary was also a child a descendant of
david
as well as joseph but let me give you
something to think about
the bible tells us that the conception
was of the holy spirit right
and so if the conception is of the holy
spirit it doesn't mean that god had some
intimate relationship with mary per se
do you know that a man can have his seed
taken from him
and he can it can be transported
and inseminate someone on the other side
of the planet
it's called artificial insemination and
so
right i i spoke to a rabbi once why he
actually was a jewish christian
and he said yeah i've read there in the
new testament where it says that mary
was conceived of the holy spirit but
jesus is the son of joseph
god took a seed from joseph and filled
it with the holy spirit and impregnated
mary with joseph seed
so what would have prevented god from
doing that i really didn't have a good
answer
for him because it could have happened
that way we know that jesus
there's something supernatural about him
but
so i think that that verse there's a lot
of latitude in there but we just know
that mary was a virgin the bible is very
clear about that
it was a virgin birth and you he the
bible even quotes in matthew
behold a virgin will conceive and bring
forth a son so there's no question about
that
but if humans can artificially
inseminate a person
why would we think that god can't
and i was thinking that also like how
can i don't know if this is a valid
point but um
how can joseph he's a man you know
create jesus who's god
no immortal man right well and i don't
think it happened that way
i think that jesus uh there was
something definitely supernatural about
christ
and his birth is one example of that but
he was 100 human so
the bible refers to this as the mystery
of godliness how god became a man
the incarnation is a great mystery for
us i don't think science can explain it
and we're sort of
we're we're you know tiptoeing around
the unknown when we try to explain that
and you know if somebody's going to
believe the bible there's there's little
doubt if you're looking
first luke chapter 1 verse 35
this is the angel speaking he makes it
very clear he says the holy spirit will
come upon you the angel is talking to
mary and the power of the
highest will overshadow you also that
holy one who is born of you will be
called the son of god so
you can't really get about or get around
that this this was directly the result
of the holy spirit doing a miraculous
work
in mary so hey we thank you very much
damon hope that helps a little bit
talking about the incarnation we've got
michaela listening in massachusetts
michaela welcome to the program
hi pastor thank you so much my question
is
should christians invest in the stock
market
um well you know there's no verse uh per
se on the stock market but jesus does
share a parable where
and i forget where that is in matthew
john where uh the
parable of the talents where jesus said
uh
this is unfaithful servant and he takes
his master's money and he buries it and
master comes back he gives it back to
him and the master said you wicked and
lazy servant you should have at least
invested it with a banker so i
could have got my interest well what
bankers do is they invest in the stocks
and so jesus said you know if you invest
in companies that over time are shown to
do better
than regular you know small investment
of a bank our mutual fund is basically
getting a fund of stocks there's nothing
wrong with investing in companies
now i personally i invest a little bit
in the stock market i don't day trade
and i don't invest in tobacco companies
i i don't invest in
disney or some some of these
entertainment companies that try and
invest in things that a christian can
morally
say this sounds like a good company to
do any good work and i'm going to invest
in them
but so i don't know if that helps you at
all i i don't think we ought to be
gambling where you're trying to day
trade and speculate
but when you put your money in the bank
what do you think the bank does
they invest in the stocks yeah
okay thank you very much all right thank
you
next holder that we have is vanessa
listening from los
angeles vanessa welcome to the program
hi
thank you for taking my question so my
questions regarding marriage
okay um my boyfriend and i have been
together for a long time
are committed to each other but are of
different
christian religious backgrounds and i
just want to know how
we can go about um a union before god so
that we can
you know be married but you know
respecting each other's
religious views well you know what paul
says
he he says you should not be unequally
yoked together
and there there's a real problem if
people marry and they do not have
they're not
united in their faith now when you say
you're of different religious
persuasions you mean different
denominations of christian or
different religions yes different
christian denomination
do you mind my asking how big the
difference is
i i mean like if if one of you is a
methodist and one of you is a baptist
you'll have problems but it won't be as
bad if one of you jehovah witness and
one of you is a
and he was raised fda
but you know i don't think you should
get married until
you are in agreement about your faith
because it really is a problem when
um you know just in the example that you
just cited
uh you know if if you probably if you've
been dating for a while you know there's
some significant differences
and and um yeah even like if you have
kids and you say well what day we're
going to go to church
you're going two different days that'll
wear them out
so yeah you you want to be of the same
faith
you know i think this is a great
opportunity if two people are thinking
about getting married of course that is
a very important decision
uh the least they could do is sit down
and study out what the other person
believes and just have an open and frank
bible study look at the differences and
ask which is closest to the word of god
sometimes we're going to
go against maybe our family background
or the tradition that
has been prominent in our household and
and seek to know god's will after all if
you want god's blessing
on your marriage you want to make sure
that you're following the bible as close
as possible so
there is an opportunity for that and we
encourage you to do that vanessa find a
some good lessons amazing facts has some
lessons that'll actually help people
go through the bible and learn very
important bible principles and that's
for free
at the amazing facts website yes
absolutely recommend that
and go through a set of studies together
and see if you guys can um
you know it can two walk together unless
they're agreed
and that's jesus and i think jesus was
quoting
hosea when he said that but um thank you
vanessa
and do we have no we don't have time for
another question oh
listening friends we see you george and
sylvia diana troy we did not get your
question tonight we hope you give us
another chance
friends hope you'll go to the amazing
facts website you can
study and listen all week long
amazingfacts.org
god willing we'll get together and study
his word again together
next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
[Music]
okay friends let's start with the basics
we know we're here
but we're not here for very long so the
most important thing would be
if we could learn during this life how
to live forever
this is the central focus of amazing
facts now there's a lot of wonderful
things that christian ministries do
i believe in christian education but if
the schools
lose the message of salvation you end up
with more educated sinners
i think it's very important for us to
build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells
i think it's important to have a medical
ministry and build hospitals
but if they separate that from the
message of salvation
you just prolong a sinner's life for a
little while that's why for years
amazing facts has made it our focus to
present the saving truth
that sets people free and friends we
want to thank you for your support and
your gifts
we'll do our very best to convert those
resources into the currency of heaven
may god bless you and keep amazing facts
in your prayers
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned and updated
amazing facts 27 bible study guides
provide straightforward bible-based
answers that are enlightening
encouraging and easy to understand
giving you real relevant bible answers
to questions like
how can i have healthier relationships
when will jesus come
and much more order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling 1-844-215-7000 that's
1-844-215-7000
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org